pour un juif pratiquant le passe à la
pâques qui commémore la sortie des
hébreux d'egypte est un jour
complètement dédiée à y avait pas
question d'avoir la plus petite pensée
matérialiste comme de choisir entre
plusieurs candidats à des élections
cantonales
encore moins de signer un registre mais
il existe apparemment des arrangements
avec le ciel ce matin à la sortie de la
synagogue du boulevard foch de tous
disaient leur intention d'exercer aussi
leur responsabilité des citoyens
nous sommes intervenus auprès de la
mairie qui organise les élections pour
qu'ils rappellent bien à tous les
assesseurs que si certaines personnes
venez voter et souhaité ne pas émerger
c'était leur droit et la mairie a tout à
fait pris en compte cet élément là et je
pense que dimanche prochain les choses
se passeront comme cela je pense que sur
à peu près 5000 5 à 6000 juifs qui lie à
grenoble il y aura peut-être 100 ou 150
qui ne voteront pas les autres iront
voter c'est très probable la communauté
juive aix les bains et plus
traditionalistes mais le cas des
consciences lui a été épargné
pas de cantons renouvelables dans le
secteur